bienvenidos a mi presentación sobre
promedios promedio es un concepto que
seguramente ya has escuchado antes no
forzosamente en un término matemático
pero tal vez lo he escuchado en términos
de el votante promedio quiere que el
político haga adapta la cosa o en su
dado caso el estudiante promedio de una
clase quiere salir temprano entonces
probablemente ya este es un poco
familiarizado con este concepto y
probablemente de una manera intuitiva ya
sepas que un promedio es simplemente el
número que representa diferentes valores
es parecido a un número que representa
todos los diferentes valores para
entenderlo mejor hagamos algunos
ejemplos no sé digamos que tenemos los
números
y los voy a poner aquí me voy a tomar al
1 me voy a tomar al 3 no voy a tomar al
5 y me voy a tomar también al 20 ok y
bueno qué te parece si yo te pregunto
por el promedio de estos cuatro números
bueno para sacar el promedio de estos
cuatro números hay que sumar cada uno de
ellos y dividirlo entre el número de
números que tenemos por ejemplo lo voy a
apuntar aquí esto me quedaría como uno
más tres más cinco más veinte y bueno 13
más 5 más 20 es lo mismo que 445 es 99
más 20 es 29 ok ahora date cuenta que
tenemos cuatro números uno dos tres
cuatro tengo cuatro números por lo tanto
para sacar el promedio tengo que dividir
29 entre 4 y cuántas veces cabe 4 en 29
4 cabe en 29 a 7 por 4 es 28 entonces lo
voy a poner aquí 7 por 4 es 28 am a esto
le voy a quitar 28 y me sobra 1 ok y si
ahora quiero pone el punto decimal voy a
poner el punto justo aquí y bajó un 0 ok
y entonces 4 cabe dos veces
2.4 es 8 entonces a esto le quito 8 y me
sobran 2 y bueno no es necesario hacerlo
pero vamos a acabarlo
aquí le pongo un 0 me falta un 5 por acá
5 por 4 es 20 entonces a esto le quito
20 y acabó con un residuo de 0 por lo
tanto puedo decir que el promedio y
déjenme ponerlo aquí el promedio
promedio de estos cuatro números es a
7.25 el promedio es 7.25 y espero que
esto te haga sentido porque el 7.25 es
un número que está entre estos dos
números y bueno podemos ver a éste 7.25
como una manera de representar estos
cuatro números sin copiarlos todos ahora
cabe mencionar que existen otras
representaciones que vamos a ver después
como la moda también vamos a aprender
por ejemplo que la media de la cual
vamos a hablar después es prácticamente
lo mismo que el promedio pero bueno el
promedio es un
lo que puedes usar para representar a un
conjunto de números así que déjame
borrar este ejemplo y vamos a intentar
hacer otros ejemplos que estén cerca de
tu corazón vamos a borrar la pantalla
ok perfecto ahora imagínate que en las
cuatro partes de un examen hice el
siguiente puntaje imagínate que en la
primera saqué 80 en la segunda saqué 81
ahora imagínate que en la siguiente
saque 87 en la que sigue saque 88 y
bueno yo lo que quiero saber es cuál es
mi promedio en este examen es decir
cuánto voy a sacar en ese examen y para
eso entonces vamos a hacer la suma de
estos cuatro números y dividirlo entre
el número de números que tenemos que en
este caso es 4 así que me voy a tomar la
suma de 80 más 81 más
a esto le voy a sumar 87
más a esto le voy a sumar 88 y entonces
dice 1778 es no espera espera 17 es 88
16 o deben de disculparme un poco es que
acabo de nadar casi dos horas y estoy un
poco cansado pero bueno 16 y llevamos
uno y después tengo 48 que es 32 más
unas 33 ok 33 y yo lo que quiero es el
promedio por lo tanto hay que dividir
336 entre el número de números que
tenemos que es 4 entonces a 4 cabe en
336 cuántas veces 336 bueno pues en 33
kv ocho veces 8 por 4 es 32 entonces
aquí le voy a quitar 32 no va a quedar
solamente 1 ok bajo este 6 y 4 por 4 16
por lo tanto aquí pongo un 4 y ahora sí
puedo concluir que el promedio que el
promedio
me dio es igual a 84 saqué 84 del examen
en fin vamos a poner la pantalla y vamos
a intentar hacer un nuevo un nuevo
problema ok vamos a hacer el siguiente
problema ok vamos a hacer esto un poco
más difícil imagínate que el promedio
después de hacer cuatro exámenes es 84 y
vamos a ponerlo aquí el promedio
el promedio de después después de cuatro
exámenes de cuatro exámenes ok es igual
a 84 ok ahora voy a hacer un quinto
examen para que me den la calificación
en la materia entonces lo que yo quiero
es obtener en esa materia
88 por lo tanto lo voy a poner aquí y
quiero obtener 88
en la materia en la materia ok para
obtener 88 en el siguiente examen
después de estos cuatro exámenes que
calificación debo de obtener así que le
voy a poner a x a x la calificación que
tengo que obtener lo que lo que tengo
tengo que obtener que a tener ok y como
resuelve este problema
bueno date cuenta que si yo quiero saca
el promedio de estos cuatro exámenes más
este más lo que voy a sacar en el quinto
como lo podría obtener bueno pues me voy
a fijar el promedio de estos cuatro
exámenes que es 84
es decir que el promedio esos cuatro
exámenes lo puedo representar como 4 que
multiplica a su vez a 84 ok esto es el
promedio de estos cuatro exámenes no
importa cuánto saque al final el
promedio es 84 ya esto le voy a sumar
lo que voy a sacar en el quinto examen
que es x ok y todo esto lo voy a dividir
entre la cantidad de exámenes que voy a
hacer en total en esa materia que es 5
ahora date cuenta que esta parte de aquí
está representando lo que ya está que en
los 4 exámenes esta parte de aquí está
representando que el promedio después de
4 exámenes es 84 es como se sumara 84 4
veces de hecho fue justo lo que vimos en
el ejercicio pasado y yo lo que quiero
es que este este promedio md-88 me de 88
para obtener esta calificación que
quiero la materia ahora lo que
necesitamos es resolver para x y bueno
para resolver para x déjame hacer una
pequeña línea aquí que nos divida esto
en dos o key
vamos a resolver para x y voy a
multiplicar 5 de ambos lados de la
ecuación por lo tanto me va a quedar 44
x 84
ok más x esto tiene que ser igual a 88 x
55 x eso es 40
5 x 8 40 o que estos 400 440 de lujo ok
pero 4 por 84 ya sabemos cuánto es justo
lo que hicimos hace rato es lo mismo que
320 más 16 es decir 336 336 más x es
igual a 440 ok y si queremos despejar
para x entonces voy a decir que x es lo
mismo que a 440 menos a 336 lo cual es
104 104 guau 104 lo que tengo que sacar
en el siguiente examen y si supongo que
el profesor me da puntos extras lo voy a
poder lograr porque si no de ninguna
otra manera voy a poder sacar 104 en un
examen es sacar más del 100% así que
espero que pongan preguntas extra pero
bueno vamos a repasar lo que vimos yo
tenía que el promedio después de cuatro
exámenes era 84 y yo quiere sacar 88 en
la materia y por lo tanto
y van a ser un quinto examen y yo lo que
quería saber es cuánto tenía que obtener
en ese quinto examen para sacar 88 en la
materia y por lo tanto lo que hice fue
poner 4 por 84 que es el promedio de
esos cuatro exámenes sumarle el quinto
examen y esto es dividirlo entre la
cantidad de exámenes que tenemos y
hacerlo igual a la calificación que
quería y bueno me sale una calificación
un poco difícil de obtener pero vamos a
hacer otra pregunta así que para esto
déjame abordar otra vez esta pantalla y
vamos a hacer la siguiente pregunta
siguiente problema ahora imagínate que
después de cuatro exámenes hablo voy a
apuntar aquí después de cuatro exámenes
muy promedio es 84 entonces después
después de cuatro exámenes
tengo de promedio hasta ahorita 84 84 de
promedio ok vamos bien hasta aquí hecho
es muy parecido al ejercicio pasado pero
en esta materia van a ser seis exámenes
van a ser en total seis exámenes
exámenes ahora imagínate que yo me pongo
a estudiar como loco pongo todo mi
esfuerzo y todas mis ganas y consigo
sacar en los siguientes dos exámenes
faltan los exámenes consigo sacar la
calificación máxima la cual vamos a
suponer que es 100 puntos entonces
imagínate que logró sacar en mis otros
dos exámenes 100 puntos mi pregunta es a
cuánto voy a aspirar del promedio total
en la materia cuánto voy a sacar del
promedio total en la materia 100.000
siguientes los exámenes saco 100 puntos
esforzándome con todo lo que pueda pues
vamos a resolverlo
ok pues primero voy a hablar de estos
cuatro exámenes y de igual manera voy a
poner 4
4 por 84 refiriéndome al promedio de
estos cuatro exámenes ya esto le voy a
sumar bueno pues en el quinto examen voy
a sacar 100 puntos porque voy a dar mi
mayor esfuerzo y en el siguiente examen
también voy a sacar 100 puntos porque
voy a poner todo todo todo el empeño y
todo mi esfuerzo y yo lo que quiero
hacer es esto
dividirlo todo esto dividirlo entre la
cantidad de exámenes que hay que son 6
ok voy a dimitir entre la cantidad de
exámenes que hay que son 6 y cuántos
esto bueno pues esto es lo mismo que
esto ya sabemos que es 334 por 416 336
más 100 más 100 es decir más 200 ya esto
lo voy a dividir entre 6 es decir a 536
lo voy a dividir entre 6 y cuantos esto
para sacar ese promedio bueno 536 a esto
lo voy a dividir entre 6 y dice
es cabe ocho veces ocho veces el 53 y
bueno 6 por 8 48 entonces no voy a tomar
53 menos 48 am vamos a bajar un poco en
la pantalla vamos a bajar un poco la
pantalla para seguir esta división y
entonces 53 menos 48 bueno eso es 5 y
después aquí voy a bajar este 6 y dice
56 cuántas veces caben 6 y bueno la
respuesta es 99 por 654 entonces 56
menos 54 es lo mismo que 2 ok pongo un
punto
pongo un 0 y 6 escape tres veces en 20 y
sobran 2 ok esto ya se ve con un patrón
89.3 3333 periódico o dicho de otra
manera si yo pusiera todo todo todo mi
empeño para que un siguientes déjame
subir la pantalla para que mis
siguientes dos exámenes sacarás 100
puntos entonces lo máximo que puedo
aspirar para sacar en esta materia es
y 9.333 en fin espero que esto haya sido
de tu agrado y aunque tal vez fue un
repaso para ti ahora ya tienes la idea
de que es un promedio y espero que estos
dos últimos problemas no solo te hayan
enseñado cómo hacer problemas de
promedios involucrando álgebra sino que
también te hayan ayudado en cómo saber
que también te tiene que ir en tus
exámenes para poder sacar 100 en tu
clase de matemáticas estoy seguro que
ahora estás listo para el módulo de
promedios
así que diviértete